THEY WANT TO HOLD ON TO THEIR
OWN POWER.
IT'S PATHETIC.
I'VE HAD ENOUGH.
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTING THAT 18 SCHOOL
CHILDREN WERE KILLED AND A
TEACHER TODAY IN TEXAS.
THE TOWN ISN'T FAR FROM WHERE
YOU GREW UP, SAN ANTONIO, SHAQ.
>> USED TO VISIT THERE A LOT.
PLAYED THEM IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THEY WERE IN OUR DISTRICT.
STEVE IS CORRECT.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
THIS IS WHERE ME AND KENNY COME
FROM.
KENNY'S FROM LEFT RIGHT.
I'M FROM THE BRICK CITY IN
NORTHERN NEW JERSEY.
PEOPLE GET KILLED EVERY DAY.
YOU TALK ABOUT BACKGROUND
CHECKS, BUT THERE'S A LOT THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
ONCE YOU DO A BACKGROUND CHECK,
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT THE
UNDERGROUND MARKET.
THE PLACE WHERE ME AND KENNY ARE
FROM, ANYBODY CAN GET A WEAPON.
AM I RIGHT ABOUT THAT, KENNY?
I'M NOT TALKING GOING INTO A
STORE AND SHOWING YOUR I.D.
IN THE HOOD ANYBODY CAN GET A
WEAPON.
LOOK, THIS IS SAD.
MY CONDOLENCES GO OUT.
AS A PARENT, I DON'T KNOW HOW I
WOULD REACT IF I GOT THAT CALL.
>> USED TO BE RULES.
USED TO BE CODES.
KIDS AND MOTHERS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT USED TO BE OFF LIMITS.
HOW DO YOU DO STUFF LIKE THIS?
THEN I HEARD THE KID DID
SOMETHING TO HIS GRANDMOTHER
BEFORE HE WENT TO SCHOOL.
>> SHOT HIS GRANDMOTHER BEFORE
HE OPENED FIRE IN THE SCHOOL.
>> IT'S A SAD DAY.
GOES ON EVERY DAY.
WHERE I COME FROM IN NORTHERN
NEW JERSEY, PEOPLE ARE GETTING
KILLED EVERY DAY.
CHICAGO A LOT OF STUFF GOING ON.
STEVE MENTIONED BUFFALO.
IT'S SAD.
WE ALL HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
WE HAVE TO CHECK ALL AVENUES.
DON'T TALK ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS
AND FORGET THE OTHER THINGS.
>> YOU KNOW, FIRST, STEVE IS
100% CORRECT.
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW
RESEARCH STEVE KERR AND WHERE HE
COMES FROM AND WHY HE FEELS SO
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT SOCIAL
JUSTICE, YOU TALK ABOUT AFRICAN
AMERICAN JUSTICE, YOU TALK ABOUT
GUNS AND VIOLENCE.
>> A FATHER WHO WAS
ASSASSINATED.
>> DO YOUR RESEARCH ON STEVE
KERR.
THAT MAN IS A TROOPER.
ALWAYS ADMIRED HIM.
PLAYED WITH HIM IN THE WORLD
GAMES.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD, FIRST.
SECOND, THE DEMONIC MIND IS
ILLOGICAL
ILLOGICAL.
YOU CAN'T PUT LOGIC TO HOW THAT
HAPPENED.
THERE'S NO HE WASN'T IN THE
RIGHT MIND.
DEMONIC.
THAT'S A DEMONIC ACT TO WALK
INTO AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND DO
THE THINGS HE'S DONE.
YOU KNOW, WE JUST GOT TO PRAY
FOR THE FAMILIES AND WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THIS COUNTRY IS
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
MENTAL HEALTH, PHYSICAL HEALTH
AND AS STEVE SAID THE
AVAILABILITY TO GET WEAPONS.
BEEN A ROUGH COUPLE WEEKS, MAN.
>> IT HAS.
>> BEEN A ROUGH COUPLE WEEKS.
>> THAT THING IN BUFFALO SHOOK
EVERYBODY UP.
THIS THING TODAY SHOOK US UP.
WHAT'S HEART BREAKING TO ME IN
BOTH INSTANCES, WHAT IS MAKING
YOUNG KIDS DO THIS STUFF?
THAT'S WHAT'S SCARY.
THESE LAST TWO ATTACKS WERE
CARRIED OUT BY YOUNG KIDS.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN YOUR LIFE
AT 17, 18 YEARS OLD THAT MAKES
YOU SO ANGRY THAT YOU REACT LIKE
THIS?
YOU KNOW, IT SHOULD BE HARD TO
GET GUNS.
IT'S WAY TOO EASY TO GET GUNS.
THE GHOST GUN THING IS A BIG
ISSUE IN THIS COUNTRY.
OUR POLITICIANS, THEY ARE THE
WORST EXAMPLE WE CAN FOLLOW.
THIS NOTION THAT EVERY SINGLE
THING THAT HAPPENS IN THE WORLD
WE HAVE TO VOTE AMONG PARTY
LINES.
NO MATTER WHAT THE SUBJECT IS
I'M A DEMOCRATIC, I'M A
REPUBLICAN, I'M GOING TO GO WITH
MY TEAM INSTEAD OF REPRESENTING
THE PEOPLE.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO REPRESENT ALL
EVEN IF YOU WIN AN ELECTION,
THAT DON'T MEAN YOU TRY TO SCREW
THE OTHER PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T VOTE
FOR YOU.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO WORK FOR
ANYBODY.
I NEVER WANT TO GET NUMB TO THIS
BECAUSE YOU GOT GRANDKIDS.
I GOT GRANDKIDS.
YOU GOT YOUNG KIDS.
YOU SEND THEM TO SCHOOL AND YOU
THINK -- NEVER USED TO THINK
WHEN YOU SENT YOUR KIDS TO
SCHOOL SOMETHING BAD WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
GO BACK TO SANDY HOOK AND NOW
IT'S HAPPENING YEARS LATER.
IT'S HEART BREAKING.
MY THOUGHTS ARE WITH THOSE
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS.
MAN, YOU SEND YOUR KIDS TO
SCHOOL, THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
SAFE.
>> CHUCK, YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
LOOK, MY WIFE AND I RAISED SIX
KIDS.
WE SENT THEM TO SCHOOL.
>> YOUR DAUGHTER'S A TEACHER.
>> THERE WAS NEVER AN INCIDENT.
THERE WAS NEVER ANYTHING LIKE
THAT WHEN THEY WERE GROWING UP.
NOW I HAVE FOUR GRANDKIDS.
I HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO'S A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER.
IT SCARES THE DEVIL OUT OF ME.
IT JUST -- BECAUSE I CAN'T LOOK
AT IT AGAIN.
I CAN'T SEE ANOTHER CNN REPORT
THAT SAYS THIS IS HAPPENING.
YOU THINK ABOUT 14, 16, 18,
SCHOOL KIDS.
>> ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
>> THINK ABOUT IT TOO, ERNIE,
SOMETIMES IT USED TO BE LIKE
THEY GOT CAUGHT IN THE WRONG
PLACE AT THE WRONG TIME.
SCHOOL IS NEVER THE WRONG PLACE,
ESPECIALLY WITH YOUNG KIDS.
KENNY ALWAYS SAYS THAT'S WHY
PRISON IS FULL OF IDIOTS.
THEY THINK THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
GET CAUGHT AND THEY HAVE A
DELUSIONAL MIND.
WE CAN'T MAKE SENSE ABOUT
BUFFALO OR WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
THERE'S NOTHING ANYBODY CAN SAY
I UNDERSTAND WHY HE DID IT.
IT'S INEXCUSABLE.
IT'S A SAD DAY FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> EVIL.
JUST EVIL.
OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO ALL THOSE.
LeBRON JAMES SIMPLY HAS TO BE
CHANGE, HAS TO BE.
PRAYING TO THE HEAVENS ABOVE TO
ALL WITH KIDS THESE DAYS IN
SCHOOLS.
JAYSON TATUM BREAKS MY HEART
HEARING THESE NEWS.
NO PARENT SHOULD HAVE TO LOSE
THEIR CHILD.
IT'S DEVASTATES.
CHRIS PAUL, ABSOLUTE